.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT WITH THE BIDEN ECONOMY
GOING FROM BAD TO WORSE, WELL,
THE DECREPIT DECLINE
ING AN
DESPERATE IN CHIEF IS PLAYING
ONE BLAME GAME AFTER THE OTHER
AND SPEWING ONE BIG LIE AFTER
THE OTHER AND EMBARRASSING OUR
ENTIRE COUNTRY EVERY DAY.
IT'S HUMILIATING.
WITH 25 DAYS UNTIL THE
ALL-IMPORTANT MID-TERMS,
REPUBLICANS IN DEEP BLUE STATES
ARE SURGING IN THE POLLS.
WE HAVE FULL COVERAGE AHEAD ON
THE KEY RACES.
THESE ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
MID-TERM RACES POSSIBLY IN OUR
LIFETIME.
POSSIBLY IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
GREAT REPUBLIC.
MY WORDS CANNOT POSSIBLY CONVEY
THE URGENCY I'M FEELING FOR THE
COUNTRY THAT WE ALL LOVE.
AFTER YESTERDAY'S DISMAL
INFLATION NEWS, ANOTHER 40-YEAR
HIGH, COMMON SENSE AMERICANS ARE
RIGHTLY CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR
FUTURE.
THEY ARE RIGHTLY LOSING
CONFIDENCE IN JOE BIDEN AND THE
NEW EXTREME SOCIALIST CLIMATE
CULT ALARMIST DEMOCRATS.
WE HAVE A NEW A.P. POLL OUT.
46% OF OUR FELLOW AMERICANS
CONSIDER THEIR FINANCIAL
PERSONAL FINANCIAL SITUATION TO
BE POOR, POOR.
REMEMBER, AVERAGE FAMILY IS
PAYING $7,200 MORE UNDER DONALD
TRUMP FOR THE EXACT SAME ITEMS.
BARE NECESSITIES.
NOW, IT WAS BIDEN AND HIS FAILED
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY LIED TO US.
REMEMBER, INFLATION IS
TRANSITORY, TRANSITORY.
THEN OH, INFLATION IS NOW
PEAKED.
I THINK IT'S PEAKED.
WE HAVE ZERO INFLATION ON THE
DAY IT CAME OUT TO BE A 40-YEAR
HIGH.
OR THAT INFLATION WOULD BE THAT
BAD AT ALL.
IT WAS LIE AFTER LIE AFTER LIE.
HERE'S A QUICK TRIP DOWN MEMORY
LANE MONTH AFTER MONTH AFTER
MONTH OF JOE BIDEN'S ECONOMIC
HELL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> COST OF THE BUILD BACK BETTER
BILL IS ZERO IN TERMS OF ADDING
TO THE DEFICIT.
THE COST OF THESE BILLS IS ZERO.
ZERO.
>> IT'S ALL PAID FOR.
IT'S ALL PAID FOR.
SOME FOLKS HAVE RAISED WORRIES
THAT THIS COULD BE A SIGN OF
PERSISTENT INFLATION.
THAT'S NOT OUR VIEW.
>> OVER TIME AS THE ECONOMY
TURNS BACK ON, WE'LL SEE
TRANSITORY EFFECTS.
>> INCREASES IN PRICES ARE
LIKELY TO HAVE TRANSITORY
EFFECTS ON INFLATION.
>> TRANSITORY.
>> TRANSITORY EFFECTS.
>> TODAY'S INFLATION REPORT
CONFIRMS WHAT AMERICA HAS
ALREADY KNOWN.
PUTIN'S PRICE HIKE IS HITTING
AMERICA HARD.
>> OIL COMPANIES.
>> SHIPPING COMPANIES.
>> WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN.
>> TODAY WE LEARNED THAT LAST
MONTH OUR ECONOMY HAD 0%
INFLATION.
>> I WANT TO SAY A NUMBER, ZERO.
>> TODAY'S REPORT SHOWS
PROGRESS.
OVERALL, INFLATION WAS 2% OVER
THREE MONTHS.
>> Sean: ASK YOURSELF GIVEN ALL
OF THESE LIE AS FULL YEAR, ALL
OF THIS DEMOCRATIC DECEIT, ALL
OF THE DEMOCRATIC DECEPTION, HOW
CAN ANYONE TRUST THEM WITH MORE
POWER, MORE CONTROL AND THE
ABILITY TO RUIN YOUR LIFE IN
EVERY WAY IMAGINABLE?
LOOK AT THE STOCK MARKET.
IT IS CONTINUING TO CRATER.
401(k)s, YOUR RETIREMENT IS
SUFFERING.
CRIME IS SURGING IN SMALL TOWNS
AND BIG CITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
NO BAIL LAWS, DEFUND, DISMANTLE
THE POLICE.
INNOCENT LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS
SUFFER MORE NOW THAN EVER.
OUR BORDER IS WIDE OPEN AND IT'S
AS BAD AS IT HAS EVER BEEN.
WE STILL HAVE 2 1/2 MONTHS LEFT
IN THE YEAR.
WE SET A RECORD FROM LAST YEAR.
EVEN AMERICANS NUCLEAR FEARS ARE
NOW SURGING TO THE HIGHEST
LEVELS SINCE THE COLD WAR AS
BIDEN'S EMPTY THREATS, WEAK
DIPLOMACY CONTINUE TO FAIL IN
EVERY WAY IMAGINABLE.
JOE BIDEN CAUSED ALL OF THIS.
HE SAID WE'RE IN THE WORST
POSITION IN TERMS OF NUCLEAR WAR
POTENTIAL SINCE THE CUBAN
MISSILE CRISIS.
HE WENT ON VACATION AFTER THAT.
IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, HAVE YOU
EVER SEEN ONE MAN, ONE PARTY,
ONE POLICE CALL MOVEMENT FAIL
THIS FAST?
EVERYTHING DEMOCRATS HAVE
TOUCHED HAS BEEN MADE WORSE.
ON STEROIDS, ACTUALLY.
THAT'S WHY FAR LEFT SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO RUN AWAY
FROM THEIR RECORDS.
THIS IS HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY, ALL AHEAD OF THE
CRITICAL MID-TERMS.
IT'S WHY SO MANY DEMOCRATS ARE
NOW AVOIDING THAT GUY, JOE, JOE
BIDEN AT ALL COSTS.
THEY DON'T WANT HIM ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
TIM RYAN, IN OHIO, HE'S TRYING
TO HIDE HIS FAILED RECORD, HIS
SUPPORT OF ALL THINGS JOE.
HIS SUPPORT OF NEW GREEN DEAL
SOCIALISM.
HE'S ALSO AVOIDING JOE BIDEN.
MARK KELLY, ARIZONA, 97% OF THE
TIME VOTES WITH JOE BIDEN AND
CHUCK SCHUMER.
HE'S A RUBBER STAMP FOR
EVERYTHING THAT HAS GONE BAD.
BY THE WAY, JOE BIDEN HAS GIVEN
HIM THE COLD SHOULDER.
WE'RE SEEING THE SAME STORY IN
RACE AFTER RACE, STATE AFTER
STATE.
DEMOCRATS ARE HIDING FROM
DEBATES, THEY'RE HIDING FROM THE
VOTERS.
THE MEDIA IS COMPLICIT.
THEY'RE GIVING THEM A FREE PASS.
THEY'RE NEVER DEMANDING ANSWERS
TO ANY TOUGH QUESTIONS.
THEY'RE NOT HAVING TO ANSWER FOR
THEIR RADICAL POSITIONS THAT
THEY HOLD.
IT IS THE BIDEN BASEMENT BUNKER
STRATEGY.
THEY'RE TRYING TO RUN AWAY FROM
THEIR FAILED FAR LEFT RECORDS.
I CAN'T SAY I BLAME THEM.
PROBABLY THE ONLY DEFENSE THEY
HAVE.
THAT'S WHY WITH ONLY 25 DAYS
UNTIL THE MID-TERMS, THERE'S
MORE AND MORE SIGNS OF THE GOP
GAINING MOMENTUM.
MARK PENN, A FORMER CLINTON
POLLSTER SAYS THE GOP IS CLOSER
TO A WAVE ELECTION.
ECONOMIC ISSUES LIKE INFLATION
WITH RECORD GAS PRICES, RECORD
CRIME, RECORD MURDER, OPEN
BORDERS CONTINUE TO BE AT THE
TOP OF VOTERS' MINDS AND IT
SHOULD BE.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE'RE NOW SEEING
REPUBLICANS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, THEY'RE SURGING AT JUST
THE RIGHT TIME.
YOU CAN SEE IT WITH DR. OZ IN
PENNSYLVANIA, WITH J.D. VANCE IN
OHIO.
YOU CAN SEE IT WITH ADAM LAXALT
IN NEVADA AND RON JOHNSON IN
WISCONSIN.
HERSCHEL WALKER IS THIS CLOSE
NOW TO OVERTAKING RAPHAEL
WARNOCK.
EVEN IN DEEP BLUE OREGON, THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE OUT THERE,
CHRISTINE DRAZEN, SHE'S OPENED A
BIG LEAGUE AGAINST THE FAR LEFT
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS ARE VULNERABLE.
THEY CANNOT DEFEND THEIR FAILED
RECORDS.
THEY CANNOT DEFEND THE RECORD OF
THEIR PARTY.
THEY CANNOT DEFEND THEIR
PRESIDENT EITHER.
ALSO DEVELOPING TONIGHT, EVEN
MORE ED OF WHAT APPEARS TO BE A
MASSIVE MID-TERM ELECTION
MEDDLING SCANDAL.
IT SURROUNDS JOE BIDEN.
I'M SURE THAT THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA IS GOING TO IGNORE THIS.
BUT IMAGINE AS I TELL YOU THIS
STORY, IF THE LAST NAME WERE
TRUMP, PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT DID
THIS, WE KNOW NOW THAT SAUDI
ARABIA AND OPEC +, THE PLUS THAT
INCLUDES RUSSIA, THEY DENIED JOE
BIDEN'S REQUEST TO INCREASE OIL
PRODUCTION AND NOT ONLY THAT,
THEY TOLD JOE BIDEN THAT THEY
WOULD BE DECREASING OIL
PRODUCTION.
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO NEGOTIATE
OR SAYING THE HELL WITH YOU,
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, IT TURNS OUT THE
SAUDIS ARE TELLING US THAT JOE
BIDEN AND HIS ADMINISTRATION
THEN WAS BEGGING THE SAUDIS TO
HOLD OFF ON OIL CUTS AND AN
ANNOUNCEMENT OF OIL CUTS UNTIL
AFTER NOVEMBER.
SO I'LL ASK AGAIN, DID YOUR
PRESIDENT, JOE BIDEN, ATTEMPT TO
COLLUDE WITH THE SAUDIS WITH
OPEC NATIONS, WITH RUSSIA IN A
WAY THAT WOULD IMPACT THE 2022
MID-TERM ELECTIONS?
IN OTHER WORDS, HIDE THEIR
FAILURE AND DISASTROUS POLICIES.
THE AN IS OBVIOUS.
WHAT IS WORSE, NOT ONLY DID THEY
REFUSE TO INCREASE PRODUCTION OF
OIL, THEY DECREASED IT.
THAT'S A SLAP IN THE FACE.
AFTER BIDEN MENTIONED
RETALIATION, THEY SAID, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
WE'RE GOING TO EXPOSE WHAT YOUR
PLAN WAS.
BE QUIET AND COLLUDE WITH YOU
AND HIDE THIS FACT FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE LEAD UP
TO A MID-TERM ELECTION IN
AMERICA.
SO COLLUSION WITH HOSTILE
FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
TO INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME OF
ELECTIONS.
THIS IS A DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN
COMPLETE AND UTTER DISARRAY.
DOUBLING DOWN ON THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE AGENDA IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY.
IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP WAS
ASKING THE SAUDIS, WAS ASKING
OPEC, ASKING RUSSIA, YEAH, DON'T
ANNOUNCE THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO INCREASE PRODUCTION, YOU'RE
GOING TO DECREASE PRODUCTION.
WAIT A MONTH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE MEDIA
WOULD BE SAYING?
WOULD THEY BE ACCUSING HIM OF
COLLUDING WITH FOREIGN ENTITY,
HOSTILE NATIONS TO INFLUENCE THE
ELECTION?
I'M SURE YOU'D HEAR IT EVERY
SECOND, EVERY MINUTE, EVERY HOUR
OF EVERY DAY.
THAT'S WHY PROMINENT DEMOCRATS
ARE LEAVING THE PARTY
ALTOGETHER.
FORMER CANDIDATE AND CONGRESS
WOMAN, TULSI GABBARD ANNOUNCED
HER DEPARTURE EARLIER THIS WEEK.
SHE CITED CENSORSHIP.
DENIAL OF OBJECTIVE TRUTH.
FAR LEFT WING LUNACY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE WOKE POLITICIANS IN
WASHINGTON, A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE WHO ARE UNABLE TO --
UNABLE AND UNWILLING TO DEFINE
WHAT A WOMAN IS.
IT IS THE HEIGHT OF HYPOCRISY
FOR THOSE WHO CLAIM TO BE
FEMINISTS FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY WHO CLAIMS TO BE CHAMPIONS
FOR WOMEN OVER DECADES, FIGHTING
FOR THE RIGHTS OF WOMEN,
FIGHTING FOR EQUALITY, FIGHTING
FOR THAT LEVEL AND FAIR PLAYING
FIELD ACROSS OUR SOCIETY.
IT IS THE HEIGHT OF HYPOCRISY
FOR THESE VERY SAME PEOPLE TO
DENY THAT THERE'S SUCH A THING
AS A WOMAN.
THOSE WHO DON'T BELIEVE TH